we welcome back everyone how dare you
not do I brings in my head Leslie I need
a verbal dating okay okay well gir about
the judge Julian pasa
this episode is brought to you by list
guys during the ride sharing company
that believes in treating its people
better for lyft calm / savagely and you
get a $500 new driver bonus or looking
for new drivers guys it's a great gig go
- ly ft.com / annejulien limited time
only terms apply check it out
you won't be sorry also get the
newsletter that would fill you in on
everything everyone's talking about
which is the skin right now go to the
skin that's th e sk IMM comm saw
scheduling enter your email click
subscribe and that's it no money nothing
you get filled in on all the top news
stories so you can you know dominate
your conversations at work it's not the
golf that is the goal that goes it
perfectly in your morning dominating
routine
there you go to the skin calm flush
anything and you have a chance to win a
$250 Visa gift card oh god what have you
worked with someone that like you're
just every day you show up to work and
you're just trying to have small talk in
their district domination domination
ruthless I've been watching too much
doctor disrespect yeah I think that's
what that is for those who don't know
doctor doctor disrespect is arguably the
biggest person on the platform that is
twitch right now at least yeah
25 million every single stream what does
that mean people are watching
but that waited 25 thousand he calls a
point you know he's hysterical he was
like his bio is like millions of Twitter
followers and like things like that I
just really like one of the most
brilliant characterized I've seen and
over time I've never seen a character on
Twitch yeah yeah I don't I can only see
people being themselves well yeah I mean
I don't know how far that goes into like
the lifestyle category could be good to
be fair like okay let's start this over
so we watch a fair amount of twitch yeah
but at this point it's mostly
pub G which is players of known battle
ground wa tuula Julian play
in the past we have watched with some of
the lifestyle stuff some of the art
stuff that kind on gaming yeah like does
domestic Dan a character like there are
some people that have done this true
pseudo characters but he's doing it in a
game in the gaming yeah which is very
different than he or not yeah he's not
playing a video game as himself II sling
as a character it's a it's a grown man
Miranda sings for twitch yeah I wouldn't
even love him in that category because
it's like he is he's he's arguably one
of the best he's arguably one of the
best pub G players you know topped
whatever 50 25 right now he was a game
designer for he was a level designer
college I did yeah so he's got a
background video games
his name's guy guy Baum I think you
pronounce his last name Bobby he's like
six eight he's very tall but he's done
like Jason our friend Jason first told
me about doctor disrespect and I was
like hesitant because I I was like I'm I
don't know I'm kind of on twitch to just
like watch people I don't really need to
see a character like I like literally
didn't even watch him he told me sounds
corny he ideas on scoring it also just
sounds like I don't know if that'd be my
cup of tea I don't like really just kind
of pretty just prejudge it and I don't
know how I initially you know watch him
but I did somehow and I was hooked right
away because I was hysterical he plays
this over intense over alpha really
really like and what's great is like
he's playing the character but he's also
[ __ ] so good at the game yeah so it's
it's like kind of a cool little combo
where he he's talking all this [ __ ] to
like kids and like the chat and like the
other players I'm talking about how
dominating I am usually also like I am
the face of twitch I'm twitch he's
wearing this ridiculous way was my
sunglasses the entire time he plays
which I don't know it screams like eight
eight hours a day for full-time job
whatever and no it's very much a lot of
dr. joy in watching what Kobe streams
every day is taking a daytime program in
crane we we've been watching a lot of
twitch in general because we've been
twitching a lot yeah the game player in
those ala Graham's hasn't had you know
vitalize but just like and added a new
sense of life into our channel on twitch
because it's like the number two or
number one game every single night on
Twitch yeah and I love it you love
watching it everyone in the ding
examines watching it I do not like all
my friends play it it's like the perfect
storm akin to the edge all my friends
are dead all of them are dead
and there may not be a 24 hour stream
happening this week
ah stay tuned for that you're still
narrowing down the exact day and yeah
you know what I mean I can tentatively
announce that it's going to be Friday at
6 a.m.
obviously that's the answer be finalized
right now recording this podcast over
the weekend so I haven't formally
announced it yet but yeah Friday at 6
animism is what I'm shooting for Friday
at 6:00 a.m. Pacific time to fix dinner
time should be 9:00 a.m. East Coast time
8 8 6 5 3 a.m. Hawaii for 3 my time
let's see what is it London time 12
hours ahead
no it's 9 hours ahead although it well
that's my 3 p.m. sorry yeah I'm doing a
24 hour stream which I promised you guys
I would do so we're doing it and I'm
excited for it but you know I'm gonna
have to feed you like I'm gonna have to
do everything for you but you're gonna
have people over to your like going to
schedule guests to come on yeah but I
can keep stop by we're going to try to
have a little little area back here
where we people can sit yeah there you
have a great time it's gonna be fun it's
gonna be a good time
we but that's for later there's
something more pressing I think we need
to talk about a lot of you have asked us
to talk about this and really this like
there's only one dimension with this
whole thing
yeah this isn't going to be the biggest
discussion then yeah I mean it's pretty
much on the same team as as you guys are
also on that team which is the Jay Paul
story scenario happening right now
making headlines all over YouTube and
elsewhere so I guess I'll start it for
the people under a rock right
so Jake Paul who is
a vlogger former Viner and younger
brother of Logan Paul has quickly become
like one of the most talked-about and
successful youtubers on the platform in
the last couple months millions of
millions of views on the daily blogs and
everything but starting to really rub a
lot of people the wrong way and the most
recent story is the posting lone story
where basically post Malone who is
friends with Ethan from h3h3 productions
they post Malone ordered a bunch of J
Palmer as sort of a joke because like
they were talking about Jay Quellin they
were sort of making fun of them whatever
on a podcast or wherever else and uh so
he bought this merch and this this part
of the story is really kind of what
fired Jenna up and also kind of neat I
was so checking because it's so like
fundamentally wrong yeah well I mean so
basically what happened was Logan Eric
not Logan I'm sorry Jake Paul stole the
infant plus Colin's address from fan joy
or fan joy gave Jake his address and and
Jake figured that he might as well go
hand-deliver this merch to post alone
see what the beef was and asked him to
the other new song and in doing so he
recorded the outside of his house he
filmed like from a third-person
perspective and then like clearly Austin
was not ready to be filmed did not want
to be filmed and Jake was like is this
cool every course we vlog this and he's
like yeah of course he genuinely put off
and on the spot was a nice guy it seems
like and from what I've heard which is
why I think this hit so close to home
for you because you are such a nice
person and you've been put on that exact
spot before yeah maybe half an hour tops
but you've been firm spot by people who
know that they can put nice kind of just
like non-confrontational people on the
spot to where they will do exactly what
they want they'll act exactly how they
want they will be welcoming so when just
just keep in mind okay this is like you
ordering some merch from your favorite
company whatever campaign is big company
adidas small company likes less than
needed or sometimes you order your
favorite merch the person who is on the
other end of that who's receiving the
order are filling
order takes your address and
conveniently comes to your house with
his millions of followers blog and it
displays your whole house for all the
people who died or anything well it's
it's just sick like imagine it's like
okay I needed to step back like 20 steps
to him because I yesterday was so
triggered I was so angry I was so upset
like usually I don't like go off on
Twitter I don't talk [ __ ] about other
YouTube creators for a reason you know
unless it really affects the community
or it affects something that's going on
with the rest of us and that's why I
said what I said about Jay Paul which
was like this is the most manipulative
self-serving you know it like just awful
illegal basis an invasion of privacy
that I've ever seen yes it really is it
has to be illegal it has to be leave
there's no way that's not illegal
imagine if your [ __ ] Jennifer Lopez
and you just you order some sneakers and
some guy that works at Nike that pack is
your thing is like oh I should just go
hand-deliver them to her house she'll
probably like that wow that guy has a
blog of millions of people maybe he
wasn't - I don't even it was out even
without that it's incredibly invasive
and indefinitely legal there's no way of
telling it but so for them the reason I
said it was self-serving was because
Jake took it upon himself to then film
it you know what I mean like even if
Jake had done that and just said he did
it
that is so problematic so illegal so
that even that is an invasion of privacy
let alone the fact that he filmed it
which really proves how truly
self-serving his actions are you mean
because he wanted to show people that he
was going to post on his house it's
everything about almost everything Jake
Paul does now and has done in the last
few weeks and months it's just it's very
very self-serving and it's very
irresponsible and reckless he doesn't
you know I I was 18 was right
I had 19 brother ones I know the
behavior that goes along with being an
entitled young person who thinks that
you know you can do whatever you want
and you you know no one can tell you
this and so I understand I understand
that but what he doesn't get is the
power in all of the reckless decisions
he's making and how it's affecting so
many people in such a serious way yeah
well I mean to step back
I was never bothered by anything the jig
Paul is doing like I think it's funny I
watched some of the stuff that goes on
you know I watch these three videos I
was bought like yeah and the community I
think at we went through this with
people that did pranks for a living you
know you go through phases of like you
know it's kind of frowned upon what
those people are doing but you know it's
not they're not doing anything wrong so
let them do what they're going to do and
then once it gets to a point where you
start affecting the lives of other
people or we need to step in and say
this is wrong like this happened with
sand pepper it happened with the fine
brothers when they tried to copy right
react world and and you know when when
it goes past the point of you creating
content for you and maybe we don't like
it but you're still within the grounds
of what you're allowed to do the
community is fine with that but when you
cross the line of like you're doing
something wrong that's actively hurting
these people we are a self policing
platform because we all know we sat here
and we discussed ad nauseam what YouTube
does and doesn't do and has control over
doesn't give rise up again on Twitter
people being like let's sign a petition
to get Jake Paul to take down his
channel which disappoints me - Michael
are you guys more than anyone know that
because you've seen us discussing it
lightly like all are good because it
just because someone's doing something
that you don't like doesn't necessarily
mean that you get to take away their
ability to post on a platform like if I
would just like to add a quick guy on a
basket point for the sake of discussion
guys obviously the self policing
platform the the YouTube world where
someone acts improperly and gets phased
out because of the community itself is
in place and will forever be in place to
some extent with that said when it when
it comes to using your platform to break
the law and endanger it is just fall
right in here
to endanger other people aka daxing post
Malone
seeing a person who you know has a lot
of people who would very likely just
show up at their house that's when it
feels like okay
someone should set it maybe not like the
petition to shut down the channel but
like I know you're making tons of money
off of this kid YouTube but why don't
you step in right now because this is in
violation almost all your Terms of
Service okay but it but when you're
violating Terms of Service
I don't I don't want to have this
conversation on whether or not a YouTube
jock alright I'm not trying to switch
Jake Paul doesn't it's alright I don't
run you don't want to have that I'm not
having that conversation I'm really just
bringing up a point for devil for devil
basket perfect purposes if you you you
obviously think that no petition should
shut down town and I'm in agreeance with
that like I'm not trying I'm not saying
that no petition should ever shut down a
channel I'm saying like if that person
is doing something that's still within
the guidelines or like maybe you can
have the video taken down that's in
question no I'm not sure yeah
good but I certainly don't think that
it's YouTube's job and I certainly don't
want to have the conversation of the
nitpicky little gritty sand pieces of
should YouTube step in and do something
I've heard of certif but you Disney
don't care about their enough service
but you did mention a few minutes ago
that what you're watching Paul is doing
aside from the post alone thing isn't
bothering him I don't I don't feel a
particular need to speak out about its
everyday bro no no no like that now that
I'm talking about what the neighbors
think are you how do you feel about that
though because that bothered me yeah not
that sucks but I don't I I don't feel a
need to voice my opinion about it Jeremy
like that that's terrible I would hate
to let I would hate to work for my
entire life like we still do not own a
home in Los Angeles is very expensive it
is very difficult these people probably
have worked their entire lives and when
keemstar interviewed that his neighbor
he was saying you know they mostly live
next to people with children and little
kids yeah and newborns they literally
live next to a newborn and I'm sorry if
I just had a baby and there's people
riding a dirt bike into a pool with 70
people at their house and then a
thousand more standing on the sidewalk I
would be pretty [ __ ] livid
yeah pretty [ __ ] women yes
but it's it's not my life Arthur I who
am I to say what should or shouldn't
happen because it's not my neighborhood
and it's on my business and I don't feel
a particular need to speak out about
that this on the other hand this
intentionally or unintentionally because
you just didn't even think about it
Jackson come on no way it wasn't
intentional is so problematic and I have
never seen someone do this on the scale
with this level of intent like I'm so
angry and upset at this because
something I think that maybe Jake Paul
just missed altogether is first of all
there's an established community people
that have been doing this for over a
decade so anytime you'd like to just
check in and see what kind of notes you
could gather from their videos or how
they live their lives you know might
serve you well but a little negative
information that maybe you should think
about is that just because you are
willing to share your life and put parts
of you onto the Internet does not mean
that everyone around you is not only is
a lot of it illegal you can't feel
people without their consent certainly
in California you are not allowed to
record people and then post that on the
internet like he did to his neighbors he
went to his neighbor's houses to
apologize secretly recorded them and
then put that audio on here with with
addresses license plates locations
everything not blurred nothing nothing
ever right which is a big deal which is
a big deal in California because this is
an entertainment place a lot of people
that work here work in the entertainment
industry laws were put in place
specifically exactly to protect those
beautiful yeah and after all of this
like you know we talked about youtubers
the first thing that came to my mind
when they were showing the outside of
the team ten house with all those people
there was me thinking of anybody that
has ever willingly wanted that before I
can't think of one I can't think of one
person that was like hey guys come to my
house and make sure you stand outside
here it's a [ __ ] petting zoo I can't
think of one the people that came to my
mind was
zoella and alfie who I have heard and
they have described that people stand
outside of their house and that is
unwilling and that they will grab an
incursion they don't encourage it but it
is like oh yeah we've had people come to
the house I don't know like the people
that I'm talking to right now the people
that listen to this podcast most of this
is talking into a vacuum because you
guys whatever you guys all know you guys
all are relatively on the same page as
we are and people don't come to our
house and only took us a couple times of
saying that for people to genuinely be
like it's never okay we would never it's
a breach of privacy and we don't have
that problem anymore yeah I mean yes um
we have one and I understand when
they're talking about the the parents
that are there I think that's a huge
part of the problem hold that for me
that's a whole nother it can be when
they were the the woman that came here
and she knocked on the door and was like
we drove an hour from Anaheim and she
had her three 16 year old daughters or
daughter and friends and she looked at
me and I was like you know it's really
kind of inappropriate for you to come to
the house because this is my house you
know if I'm in public that's generally
okay to say hello to anybody like
everybody is okay if you say hello in
public for the most part what's there
[ __ ] or having a bad day but like
when you go to someone's house and in
Los Angeles
that's illegal they have those Star
Tours but you can like drive around
neighborhoods but the second that you
step on to that property that's
trespassing and everyone in Los Angeles
knows that you don't mean so she came to
the door and she said to me like yeah
but my girls love you and someday when
you're a mother you'll understand and
you'd do anything for them and I'm like
I could [ __ ] punch you right now lady
how dare you because well you could live
literally and figuratively punch her on
your property and maybe have some dumb
[ __ ] but yeah it's it's the mentality of
the parents of them being like oh I
should just take my kids there there's
all these other people there they don't
get in trouble they can just sit outside
there all day it's something to do and
the parents are sitting there and
they're lawn chairs and safety now just
kind out but the parents don't see that
as an invasion of privacy which is the
major problem which is a huge huge
horrifying
and it stems from like a tiny little
nugget of good parenting like wanting to
do right by your child that's the
tiniest piece of this the rest of it is
delusion and inappropriate behavior
right the people who are with their kids
something sometimes under 10 year old
kids on Jay Paul's [ __ ] Street with
their lawn chairs I mean how do they not
wake up for one thing and say hey what
what the actual [ __ ] am i doing right
now as a parent as a citizen of a
[ __ ] rice street we're not organized
only to Jake Paul's house to sit outside
there so you can look at him no can you
got a [ __ ] baseball game today well
we're going to play basketball today but
[ __ ] sake he's an even if this even is
this Ricky I'm trying to be like nice
about it but even if like this person
right welcome to this on their Street
which is just so beyond selfish and
stupid to me it's not your block there
I'm [ __ ] hundreds of other people who
live there living their lives trying to
[ __ ] get by even if that's happening
even if Jay calls welcoming it as a
[ __ ] adult as he would being like how
can you how can you populate that Street
how can you like onion the lawn chair
thing that blows my mind but circling
back to when people came here and when
they said that to you the the part that
bugged me the most about that which kind
of brings back to the post alone thing
is like there's literally nothing that
you can do to look good you you have to
I personally like if you were there I
would shut the door like I'm calling the
compound and I almost did that but you
you know we're nice enough to say hi to
the girls and then like and then put it
but it's like you're putting some gonna
get sock sock top we took pictures at my
house and I'm just sitting there like
smiling you're not mommy you're like you
look really distraught like you know and
I ate smile I just it's just one of the
things I really feel like I'll never
understand and that would to that woman
I know she's never watching this because
she doesn't give a [ __ ] needed you know
do those kid because if those kids were
really you know honest genuine fans of
ours they wouldn't have showed up at our
house period there's no two ways about
it you treat someone like you follow
them on the internet and you respect
them and you meet them where you can or
you treat them like an animal
and a petting zoo and you go to their
house man there's one more there's no
there's no in-between but to that mother
I would say you got parenting all wrong
in that sense because that's [ __ ] up
and we are our own people and yes that's
the parents the parents that really
would do anything for their kids are
those parents that stand in line at
VidCon doing it [ __ ] right a short
time they take their kids they pay all
that money to go to VidCon for the
entire weekend and we still buy like
people still think that we get paid to
go to VidCon and playlist and those
things we don't that's not the precedent
never has we will never get paid for
VidCon or playlist or anything like that
other events are different that's why
you find a lot of youtubers doing their
own tours and things like that because
it is a little criminal it's like having
a concert being like Rihanna we'd love
for you to come and play to meet your
fans they just they want to meet you so
we're an issue we're going to give you a
venue do that to show up but they do
that several hundred times with
youtubers and you know they give you how
many hours maybe they don't have you
been to seven I don't know but it's not
about the money or not and I say it's
not about the money
like we genuinely want to be here but
the experience is expensive for those
families and those parents do that and
brave the screaming crowds of you know
whatever and people that they don't know
or care about so that their kids can
have a wonderful experience any time
those are the parents that would do
anything exactly those are the real
exactly examples of a parent that would
do something a child every time you see
a parent a demean greeter at anime like
they're always like [ __ ] bring it in
give me a hug here because I know what
you're going through here like this is
not expect that it's yeah that's a shock
of my body being an item pletely
sacrificing their entire weekend for
their kid to be happy which to them is
like a complete pleasure most of them
are like it makes them so happy why
wouldn't I do this those are the parents
that would do anything so that woman and
those parents that are justifying it to
themselves and to their kids that way
like oh you know I'll do anything that
you want that's what you want sure let's
drive over to Jake Paul's house
no no because you're teaching your child
how to not follow
law how to be invasive and how to be a
little [ __ ] honestly honestly it's just
easy and all it just feels like such a
short time so it's just but anyway we're
living all of that all of that all of
that the code also be suppressed had
Jake Paul or any of those people set
aside their ego for five minutes and
decided that anytime someone's outside
we're going to call police and we're
going to have them removed from the
property because it's like it's a cycle
of all these people are outside nothing
gets done about it so more people come
outside so the location is so blatantly
obvious everyone knows it and everyone
keeps going if at the first time that
you saw people who are hanging out
outside you called the police or you had
you had your own private security I'm
sorry but when someone did the math you
said Jake Paul likely is making between
a million and five million dollars a
month you're telling me you can't hire
for the purposes of the safety of
yourself and your community around you
the people that did not ask to live next
to you you can't hire your own private
security to at least monitor your
premises even 12 hours a day even during
daylight hours you know I'm saying just
to make sure that kids aren't in the
neighborhood people aren't in the street
people aren't paying around like that is
absolutely a possibility and a worthy
expense at that point you're you're
you're you're arguing reason with an 18
21 however all these a you know a young
person who's making stupid decisions
there's no reason it's not like he's
saying sitting there with his [ __ ]
checkbook saying hmm can we afford
security or can we afford five move and
that's why I'm saying like it's not only
the parents it's not only the kids it is
Jayde Paul's fallen jihad is happening
hundred percent all of that did not
bother me until he decided to dock
another person you know what I'm saying
yeah like all of this is problematic yes
all of this could be solved yes it's his
choice to continue perpetuating it fine
let's let's watch a [ __ ] train crash
shall we but then you bring an innocent
person into this and drag them down and
oh nice
that he invited them in to have a beer
that's that's when we have a problem
that's my issue that's when that's when
Ethan was like really pissed because
that's his friend well yeah and you can
tell well I pinched because you I cannot
have I'm sorry but I cannot sit around
and watch little kids six million views
are 5 million is my video thinking it's
cool to steal someone's address and film
going to their house that is not [ __ ]
cool that is not OK
that is the worst [ __ ] thing you can
do and if anybody goes to awesome house
I'm going to be [ __ ] pissed and
suppose of everybody else well they are
going to okay yes I'm so pissed
you know like show show jig Paul Rani's
motorcycle and no [ __ ] pool fine
shown being douchebag fine all that
requires some parenting and some
guidance to help kids understand the
difference between what they shouldn't
shouldn't do you know working there all
what they watch or not watch you this to
me import more dangerous and more
offensive and just more wrong than all
of that yeah like you're watching a 20
year old kid be an idiot fine I love the
real world
I love shows work I love Jersey Shore I
love watching people be idiots doesn't
mean that I'm going to be at your own
expense you know what I mean not at
other peoples expense but when you watch
someone do that and then people don't
make a big deal about why it's wrong I
worry that people will think it's okay
well I think this is very fresh and I
think in the next few days something
something is going to happen like thing
things are going to give things I mean
you cannot do what he's done on so many
different levels but specifically on the
post Milan saying you cannot you cannot
get away with that I understand where
you're triggered you know that it's
there will be something that's going to
happen it's just the way you know you
can't you can't breach that and have
nothing happen
you just can't so you know we're
recording this a day after that news
came out not even a day after that news
came out tomorrow you're going to see
this podcast I assume by even tomorrow
there's many more news about it the
repercussions what not when I dropped
from his Disney Junior opposition so but
which people were tweeting at me they
were like wolf is me drop Felix why did
they drop a shake yet and I said on
Twitter I was like
Disney only dropped Felix because they
buckled under all that intense media
pressure yeah I don't think you really
care what their people do unless they're
getting pressure from the media yeah
which is then what happened with Jay
Paul I would say is not as intense as
what happened with Beauty pies yes
because that was it now we know that
Disney also buckles under moderate media
pressure you know means yep because he
dropped me was you know left the show
but it's midseason yeah which doesn't
make sense yeah and if any of this is
coming of news to you guys you didn't
hear of any of this you're living in
Iraq maybe you need to wake up and read
this gift because you would have known
about all this so yeah if you had the
skin newsletter coming to your inbox
every morning you think this would be
honest this would definitely on the
skinny so well the Disney news what
because that's the mainstream
that's not YouTube anymore right I
didn't even know he was on that show
still I thought that was over his head
in real life it still didn't god anyway
guys the skin is great okay you're smart
but you're also busy the skin makes it
easier to be smarter it's a free
newsletter that breaks down what's going
on the world's easy fun and informative
you wake up with the skin every morning
make it part of your morning routine at
the skin comma H es que IMM dot slash
hello Julian it's free guys all we want
you to do is go to the Scimitar
confession and Julian sign up just learn
about all the news so you can dominate
conversation network and and it's free
so just sign up once you subscribe to
the skin newsletter you get the email
every morning in your inbox in a nice
package concise way so you can read the
news understand it get what you need and
then move on with your day in a more
educated fashion and you can also be
entered for a chance to win a $250 Visa
gift card so while your dogs barking at
the door you'll be reading the skin
educating yourself getting yourself
ready and learning what you need to know
for the day right now guys go to the
skin calm son Julian check it out it's
the skin with two M's thank you this
game also if you guys need a nice new
watch for an affordable price
check out movement watches guys it was
founded by the belief that style
shouldn't break the bank which I I'm a
big proponent mm-hmm because they have
really really nice luxurious looking
watches and feeling watches for
affordable prices their goal is to give
you classic
quality construction and minimalist
style at revolutionary prices it was
started by two broke college kids that
wanted to wear sauce washes but like a
lot of people couldn't afford them so
they started their own company they are
the fastest growing watch company with
over 1 million watches sold in over 160
countries countries I love my room watch
it's not really nice when I wear to all
my nice events or to last wedding we
went to it's beautiful if you're looking
for watches in department stores but
they're 500 bucks maybe check out
movement watches they start with just
ninety five dollars so join the movement
get 15% off and free shipping and free
returns by going to nvm T calm /jj
that's MVM t.com /jj and lastly we want
to thank lift for sponsoring the podcast
guys what you if you're looking for work
on our lifts is looking for drivers why
don't you join the ride-sharing app that
treats their drivers right guys you can
make hundreds of dollars per week plus
tips drive for lyft right now and you
get express pay which means you don't
have to wait to get paid you cash out
almost instantly and you get to keep
100% of the tips and those tips add up
fast list was the first ride sharing
platform with tipping built right into
the app which in my opinion is the right
way to be because I'm coming around you
need to get a tip and so far lyft
drivers have been paid over 200 million
dollars Holly and that feature was
introduced they even taken the guesswork
out of pickups the new amp device color
codes the drivers car to your app so you
know which lyft is yours if you're in a
crowded area which is really smart and
awesome happy drivers mean happy
passengers that's why 9 out of 10 lift
rides get a perfect five-star rating so
join the ride-sharing company that
believes in treating people better go to
El yft calm civilian and you get a $500
new driver bonus if you're looking for
work I've you make your own hours you
clock in clock out when you want highly
recommend it check it out
thank you sponsors mmm thank you
sponsors I mean I don't dislike Jade
ball at all I mean that's the thing he's
done nothing wrong to me he's in a human
being sensing he's just being an idiot
yeah and there's no reason ahead I'm
sure you guys have plenty of extra
dances like this but the the internet
space is where we work and it's you know
we know a lot of people in the internet
space but like I can not be a huge fan
of what you put on the internet but if
you're a cool person I'm down with you
there's no reason for me not to like you
you know some people in the community
might act differently than that some
people might not like you if you make
annoying content or things that they
don't agree with that's fine I'm not
like that I'm genuinely like if you're a
cool person
that's that's more important to me than
what you make I don't care for me trash
all those other cool person if you make
if you make extreme trash then they
won't like it
you know II mean it's like I'm not I'm
not a big sand pepper fan probably will
not hang out with him or be down with
him just because I really not a fan of
some of the personal and professional
decisions that he's made it's different
you know I'm saying friend of Mozart
like even if I didn't enjoy your content
and you were a cool person that's fine
with me
well Chrysler theatre is a dachshund
it's the dog thing it's just beyond it
enters a whole new realm agreement
crossing the line I'm so willing to be
like there's probably a good person in
there you were fine before and then the
daxing was the line that just italy is
the only only reason and not like Jake
Paul well I like I know 20 year olds
I've been a 20 year old just like I said
your brother and and you know anybody
that you hang out with us in that age
period you have a certain level of
tolerance for some [ __ ] movies are
like a 20 year old kid he's so [ __ ]
learning and figuring out his way in the
world yeah he will figure it out maybe
the hard way but you can't just like
party and do whatever you want your
rental property and and be a nuisance to
your neighbors and not have consequences
for that but it's not my responsibility
to care or upset hey I agree with that
and I also agree with the side that says
I'm so angry Jay Paul i [ __ ] hate him
you know I get both sides I really do
and what what really kind of baffles me
is like as a youtuber as someone who
who's on a platform where you are not
the first person on this platform you
were not the first person to have this
meteoric rise have this following have
this huge moment right now this is not
the first time it's happened so as a
person like Jay Paul who's having this
happen how are you like that
kind of oblivious to the cycle of like
if you if you get this crazy blow-up
moment where everyone's watching on if
you act improperly it's going to go away
so fast that you you've seen it time and
time again like you mentioned the Sam
pepper like anytime you can remember
someone acting so stupid online they've
disappeared and they get phased out and
that's that's the nature of yes but it's
also the hubris of him being the perfect
age to think that that exactly if it's
all right if it's right into his mind to
know girl whatever in it you know it
will keep going but I think that people
continue to underestimate how important
it is to not isolate yourself like just
being cordial around other people in the
community you know I mean like you can't
create enemies within the community on
purpose just because you think that
you're better than that
you know so you have some falling out
between friends or professional or
personal differences between people like
out here I've been taking the time to
get to know anybody or do anything
you're already isolated in the community
and now you're doing things that are
only further isolating yourself from the
community I don't I don't think you
thought about or people there in that
position think about how difficult it is
once you've lost the community's respect
to sort of come back from that even if
you know even if you can continue making
a living for a long time which I hope he
does I hope there you figures out help
you grows up you know I hope you make
the right decisions like you don't you
know I wish bad on him at all but I
think it will be difficult for him in
the future to try to win people over who
are in this world because you know
people are starting to form pretty solid
opinions about him now yeah which is
only the beginning I I find it very
interesting looking at Jake and Logan
together and the difference in how
they're acting throughout the this whole
thing I think Logan's about 2425 he's a
bit older it's interesting for me to
watch what they're doing together the
music videos the beef online all of the
sort of hype that they are creating
which in my opinion as much as I like
the content with absolutely not for me
it was kind of
like they were getting millions and
millions of views ever doing a perfect
repair adobea oh it was I mean it was
really it was everybody brilliant it was
well formulated well executed and well
played up and they they got what they
needed from it they got huge huge boost
in their numbers and all students of the
work it's interesting for me to watch
right now where they had that sort of
thing go and then Jake kind of goes off
in this direction where he's being a
little reckless and he's affecting other
people and he's being a twenty-year-old
and Logan is quietly just kind of
continuing with him while not really
linking as much as he needs to to Jake
which is is you know he's a businessman
right he's making smart moves
because he knows maybe I'm old enough to
see what you're doing over here is not
great for business so when Jake started
branching off and being a little bit
reckless Logan is is quietly just kind
of doing his own thing now and I think
that is something that a lot of people
aren't really paying attention to at
this moment where it's like okay before
they were just the brothers who were
doing these goofy music videos that
everyone really liked wanting to shed on
but at the end of the day or they were
doing a good job of making themselves
relevant and entertaining entertaining
content and this and you know say what
you about Logan poly is an entertaining
person whether you hate him or love me
is like he's I mean you know that I have
a bias with Logan Paul like he reached
out to me years ago when he was
transitioning from vine or he was on
vine and I have a soft spot for Logan I
always will because he was a creator he
genuinely made me laugh on vine I saw
one where he's rolling rollerblading
around his underwear doing [ __ ]
splits and I was like crying laughing
because I was a gigantic fan of vine
like that's what I would do those do it
much - and he reached out to me with a
genuine question which a lot of people
ask me when they're at that particular
crossroads Robbie asked me like there's
a lot of people that just genuinely want
to talk to someone that when Logan asked
me when he was in college when he was in
his freshman year of school or sophomore
year and he was like you know as someone
that had had finished our education and
now was working in this world you know
what do you think do you think that I
should stay in school or should I drop
out and you guys already know my answer
I'm an education pusher I was like here
the benefits
you saying in school and why I think
it's important for you but it's also
your decision and there are also
probably a lot of benefits for you
pursuing what you feel like you need to
pursue and you know I left that door
open when I talked to Logan in
particular but I did preach the
importance of my opinion of Education
and he decided to you know move on with
his life and not finish school become
incredibly successful by the way and and
he did and he is and from what I've
heard and I've met Logan multiple times
I don't think I've met Jake but Logan is
a nice person he's the epitome of what I
say like even if he made something that
maybe not problematic but something that
I wasn't a super fan of Logan is a very
nice person he carries himself well he
is polite he is friendly and that really
does get you a long way in life just in
general but yeah that's just decisive is
his charisma which way the ton of and
from what I've heard from multiple of
our friends is that who have actually
worked with him is that he works hard
and he's on time and you know he's just
collaborative in nature and brings
things to the table like he's here to
work and you're here to do that and and
it only validates my experience with
Logan like even if you think he's loud
and douchey or whatever it is he is a
nice person and does carry himself like
an adult behind the scenes as far as I'm
aware yes which is and I do I have it I
just have a soft spot for a person that
even has that ethical question of like
you know what do I do with my life right
now is it should I listen to everyone
that tells me stay in school because I
should or should I drop out and pursue
this dream and it's really your choice
in yours alone but I just have a soft
spot for someone that has that question
yeah and that does that and then
continues to pay their own path yeah and
he does carry himself differently than
Jake and you get your lungs have your
own booze only mine well no he generally
carries himself differently but he's
he's treating his his time and his
position on the Internet in a much more
delicate way than Jake is Jake is being
way more reckless and at this speed Jake
is going to be irrelevant really fast
and Logan
Wow about that okay well that's my
opinion that's here I think when you act
like this you go to a relevancy way
faster than anyone else I think Logan
like you said if even if he doesn't rub
you the right way he is on this path and
he's doing the right things to stay on
this path Jake in my opinion it's being
completely idiotic and he's going to get
off that path as fast as he jumped on it
at this rate going to people's houses to
breaking the law ruining other people's
lives on his [ __ ] block like that's
how you go into relevancy in my opinion
that's just my opinion I what I was
trying to do was just bring up the fact
that I think Logan who I don't really
know personally but it's interesting to
see the distance created right now
between oh he's not skating my I see
teachers partner he's not he's not
literally backing up every move of Jake
which i think is smart because if you do
that you're you're more than brothers
with him you're associating almost as
business partners where you're like I
backed these decisions where she does it
he's smart enough to not back the
decisions of his brother right now
well anyone that's ever had a brother -
it's like I'm related to them but I'm
not responsible for some of the shape
that they're doing I can't I told my
brother don't look at me I got your back
he's an adult I got your back but if
your backs on postpones lawn right now I
don't got it like I got your back but
don't you know what I mean what ruin
what you know what I think that there's
a genuine chance for Jake Paul to not
just you know piss everyone off so bad
that he becomes a relative - dude I
think this is all inclusive I think that
that meant a genuine way you know you
have to also remember that his core
audience is people that do not care
about anything that we're saying right
now they just want to fall into fall in
their their younger kids yeah yeah and
they don't care about this stuff this
doesn't matter nor I'd even paying
attention to it because it's not safe
they were outside their car there keeps
varying options they're concerned with
the the next thing that you doing and
the girl he's dating and you know all
that they don't care about any of this
and they're not even aware of it so I I
don't understand agree with you that
just because he's being a douche means
that he could just run his career into
the ground because I think there's a lot
of opportunity for him to stay like as
popular and whatever is he is well
so kind of just pissing people off it'd
be his audience is still his audience I
just I think there's there's only that
path is only so long you can only do
that I think the only thing that's going
to really stop him is just the long arm
of the law because there is a penalty
jail time I do think that they will be
relatively leaning on him because as far
as I know he hasn't been arrested and
you know charged with felonies and [ __ ]
in the past so they have no reason to
give him the Mac maximum sentence unless
they were trying to make an example of
him because I have to imagine I said
this immediately after nothing was that
it if stuff like this keeps happening
and people who you know our future
youtubers our future social media stars
see this team 10 as the template of what
they would like to build their following
off of and then they think that that is
what they do like we're all didn't live
in a house together everybody's like
yeah yeah like I said the the city of
Los Angeles could in theory create some
new legislation for people and scenarios
just like this so the only way that he
would face actual jail time is if they
took all of this into consideration
close him alone included which would
require post alone to file some type of
charge against him which she awesome
seems too nice and too busy and just
above it to ever do that although I hope
that Ethan is over there being like so
we do it because it's really wrong and
it's really illegal and it's really
terrible I feel awful for awesome I mean
maybe in two years we'll look back and
say oh remember the case of Jay Paul
versus West Hollywood and now how it
changed legislation I mean maybe that
you know what I mean like that this is
the exact sort of thing where there's a
night crowd enough people affected where
it could be a made an example right well
and there's also a lot of laws in place
to protect people in Los Angeles
yeah and this my specifically LA because
of the nature of the city and they're
all they're mostly traditional actors
and actresses where it's like if you set
foot on here you will be arrested there
might be a different type of law for
just like loitering around you know
well I can't
personally think of any specific
legislation that has been made
specifically for the internet like the
Internet age right right so this could
be any none sure there are small ones or
whatever that I don't know but this
could be a really big one for them to
make an example of yeah well it's just
going to depend on whether or not they
want to make an example of him or
they're going to go easy on him and hope
that he gets it yeah from where I'm
standing right now I don't think it's
you know everything that was said right
here I still don't think it's too late
for Jake like I still think he can turn
it around if he wanted I think if he
wanted to you know right the wrongs that
he's kind of committed in the last few
months go to the people that he's
affected and actually done some you know
do something to change your course of
your actions yeah you know I think he
can move on and get off almost
scratch-free but it doesn't seem like
he's on that trajectory it just seems
like he is going more and more reckless
because it's he's a bad boy right and he
he's he's breaking all rules and he's
the most popular and this and that you
know it's just it feels like there's no
getting to him it's like such a distinct
feeling when you're trying to reason
with a person like that I mean if they
wanted to do that kind of thing like if
they wanted to ride dirt bikes into
swimming pools and stuff like that then
you don't live in not only hope so you
go by a lot up yeah you go by a lot in
like Calabasas and have all this space
and three dozen teenagers only no but
like I know you can find a place where
there's like that yeah where it's going
to be far fewer in between where people
are like hey this is bothering me
because you have the feasible space to
do whatever you want the behavior in and
of itself innate behavior I mean aside
from lighting [ __ ] on the fire in the
pool that's not yours if you're renting
a house the behavior that is in riding
dirt bikes teen lab party innately I
guess on paper it's not technically
wrong if you're on the right spot for it
and he's not he's in the exact right
spot for right well I think that that
along with encouraging and not doing
anything about the level of security
Blake all of the reality shows that you
love where people do dumb stuff like
jackass
and whatever they're not the only [ __ ]
they do in the middle we all is like a
parking meter fairy and like get
arrested in a city all of the the stunts
all the noisy stuff all of the angry
stuff is all like in a place where
you're not affecting other people
because even shows like that they know
and are hyper aware of like I'm willing
to put my body at risk my life at risk I
wanted to be a complete [ __ ] idiot on
camera but everyone around me is not and
I will not subject them to it yeah
although they did do some of those
pranks where it's like there's people
there and obviously that yeah you see
blurred faces everywhere well yeah right
responsibility comes with having a
camera in a big audience and when you
don't let your faces it's not good or or
addresses and one up yeah but you know I
really think the next few months are
going to be interesting to watch what
plays out and well I think that the
reason that I wanted to talk about it is
a because the daxing things like
actually triggered me I'm like actually
angry I'm actually upset and that's a
big note and it also makes me scared
that some kid is going to watch that
that works at a place where they have
information like that and they're going
to be like oh dude Paul went to post
Malone's house I'm just gonna I'm going
to one-up him and I'm going to go to
[ __ ] P Diddy's house like it's I
think it just sets a scary precedent for
people showing up at people's houses
that's crossing one yeah and and be
because I think that what he's doing
will affect the community in some way
yep and that's why I wanted to talk
about it even even with everything
that's going on I think whatever this
judge because I don't think this has
happened in our community for where some
this is someone so so drawing attention
with just to what we do in the worst way
to where I saw even Diplo tweeted like
somebody showed me what youtubers are
and man I've never been more pissed or
something like that like you whether or
not Jake is aware of it he is bringing
attention to our community in a bad way
and it does paint all of us out to be
these dumb camera holding stunts prank
loving little
entitled egomaniacs you know which
really sucks which not all of us are
some of us not Wow good discussion good
talk yeah yeah I really don't know what
to time I mean I will just see my how it
goes and I hope you guys got something
out of our discussion here I hope we
could if you didn't really know what
fully was going on or didn't really
understand all the facts I hope we could
shed some light to it and started
discussion but we want to know what you
guys think about the whole thing about
Jake about the daxing about before the
daxing let us know in the comments we
want to hear what you have to say I am
and next week we'll be back with another
podcast talking about something that's
bursted hell yeah Harold you marry you
okay thank you sponsor support check
them out in the description below see
you guys doing
[Music]
[Music]